das gibt's nicht ich konnte einfach
kippen kommen wir dauernd bittet jeden
alters s kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge mit einer neuen
challenge die challenge die wir heute
spielen möchte ich die gestalt wandert
challenge nennen denn die funktioniert
folgendermaßen ich werde immer die
gestalt der person die ich gerade
getötet habe annehmen und das heißt
gestalt annehmen dass ihre rüstung nehme
und die person ihr hat jetzt nur ein
eisen helm so sagt also habe ich mit den
eisen helm ohne gold leggins sie dafür
aber alles was ich bisher habe aus so
jetzt habe ich mir nur das anziehen was
erst hatte so zac ist ob ich nicht
richtig schwere challenge weil okay ich
dafür sie wieder das hinzunehmen was ich
da auf dem weg finde aber ich muss
einfach genau das anziehen was die
person vor mir hatte und es ist sehr
tricky wenn man da gerne mal abgestaubt
wird habe ich mir sagen lassen
so wie ich jetzt in ihr absterben werde
so der trick ist dabei dass man seinen
etat immer vollkommen frei von rüstung
hält damit man genau weiß was die
rüstung des gegners ist so jetzt werfe
ich das hier weg und darf anziehen was
er mir gegeben hatten dass sie doch
eigentlich ganz gut aus so und wiederum
zu entsorgen entsorgen entsorgen
und das hier können wir nicht auch weg
schmerzen so der mission zweig ist das
ist eigentlich eine richtig richtig neue
runde und nach vorne kommt ein gegner
mit dir sachen und ich weiß nicht dir
sachen schüchtern immer so ein bisschen
einer weiß gefühl
18 frei ist eine gute sache so fett wird
er sie jetzt in den nahkampf gegeben mir
oder was ist die vorliebe von wievielen
gegen eingebracht es gibt auch einige
spieler 77 spiel das noch in der runde
zuvor sich sein die challenge ist
nämlich nicht leicht weil wenn man da
mal an zwei gegnern gerät dann hat man
ein großes problem weil man muss die
russen natürlich sofort wechseln heißt
wenn ich jetzt zwei gegner angreifen die
shops ein zu töten müsste ich es sofort
die rüstung wechseln oder und boxen sich
zwei sehr geil geil geil
ja ja ja ja ja ja gerne kümmert ja ja ja
ja sehr sogar
ok dann wieder alles wegwerfen jetzt
kann ich vielleicht mit dem equipment
von ihm ins death match aber ich musste
schnell anziehen denn die gegner kommen
okay
geschafft so wieder alles aussortieren
sap kann zum beispiel sein wenn ich
jetzt so im gegner essen vor den über
genug gegen ich hab so was nicht überall
mit richtig schlechten equipment
da muss ich jetzt meine farben mit dir
panzer rüstung wegwerfen die von ihm
anziehen auch wenn es um goldhelm ist
und dann gegen den nächsten gegner
kämpfen
also es ist tricky darum kämpfen zwei
gucken ob ich da hingehen kann er
vielleicht noch mal neue kleider für
deathmatch besorgen sodass du bist im
servicefall der gefährlichere gegner hat
nummer 2 fahrer vor mir passiert bei der
folge charge das eine gute sache so muss
er jetzt oben kommt mit ja und noch
einen aller genau woher wir gegen mich
kämpfen
wir kämpfen zusammen zu echten der tnt
ist dem kann mir nichts mehr anhaben
denn wir werden direkt ins deathmatch
gepostet
wo gott ich habe jetzt zuerst habe ich 2
gegen max ist oder nicht
oder doch ich weiß es nicht vielleicht
schaue ich mal den hier drüben so als
direkten gegner hat es mir aussuchen so
mein lieber wie sieht es bei dir aus das
fechten oder nicht
ok es hintermänner - keiner soll ich
heute ganz einfach irgendwie ich weiß
nicht veröffentlich benutzen sollte zack
zack zack zack taylor ist nein nein
heißt es jetzt er hat mir nur die gold
längst gedruckt ok weg weg weg weg damit
jetzt muss ich mit der gold gegen gegen
ihn kämpfen
nein ja bitte falla holt es wird richtig
schwer leute alter
oh oh oh oh spamming ist real
ja natürlich wir jetzt den nahkampf ist
klar denn er hat das deutlich bessere
kommentar ich werde versuchen ihn zu
bremer vor verbrennt verbrennt das ist
gut denn gold apfel
das gibt's doch nicht alter oder kriegt
mehr pfeile von mir kommt kaum kontakt
kommt bitte bitte bitte bitte
nein nein er hat es geschafft und gucken
wie viele herzen dennoch hatte alter da
hat sich schon gezeigt die change ist
richtig schwierig aber wir spielen kurs
geht deswegen haben wir noch einen
zweiten versuch einen zweiten versuch
nummer 2 und die ist richtig freue mich
hat gerade eben schon jemand erkannt ich
frage mich wie die das machen
hier könnte man die kommentare schreiben
wie ihr das macht wenn ihr auch so flott
kerner seit wow
warum öffnet sich da direkt in die kiste
war oder ist einer
okay okay okay 96 tore robert okay es
kein ding kann ich da drüben leute man
da drüben ich guck mal hier auf dauer
ist drin ist goldhelm das ist solange
alles was ich jetzt noch aus kisten
sammle ist noch meine eigene rüstung
sehr schön und die ist entscheidend
dafür ob ich aus dem ersten fight
überhaupt als überleben da rauskomme
so wie es bei dem ausland nicht so krass
damit habe ich da durch die
fensterscheibe erkennen können oder habt
ihr gesehen wie viel mir gezogen hat
alter und meditiert es übertreibt und
der schulpauschale gambro mich zum
arrows maine wo es sehr gut so was du
für mich hast dass du für equipment
könnte aber reichen es könnte reichen
und der heißt da gibraltar drauf drauf
nein nicht wieder glück da kommt man
kaum jemand nein es ist grad ist es noch
der der mich erkannt hat es ist genau
der mich erkannte der mich jetzt hier so
jetzt wieder mit den weg abschneiden der
mich hier so energisch jagd sowie sich
gegenseitig angegriffen haben die beiden
aber nicht so wie es aussieht komisch
oder ohne jetzt kriegt ja internet so
wie wäre es wenn ihr euch mal
gegenseitig angreifen
ökonomie alter schwierig dass hier mit
sehr gerne
das ist alles ein gesamtes equipment
nicht durch einen klick erscheint
unterliegt eisen schwert vor gott das
ist geil und auf dem der jazz vielleicht
oder hier
und das sieht auch schon mal deutlich
besser aus die ist leider kein bogen
leider kein bogen und das deathmatch es
nah dass nato wir können ja mal kurz es
zwei verlorene spiel das sieht man auch
ohne mich an nick jannik machen wir
nicht nein großtrappen stattdessen wolle
man lieber mal feierten würde ich sagen
sonst kaum wo ich bin immer nicht voll
korrekt man nicht mehr
doch markt aber sehr langsam sehr
langsam ist ja was nein egal ob das bad
am bogen dass die frage jetzt am boden
nein schüttelt tisch ich mache kurz noch
mal erklärt wir haben diese runde das
glück gehabt dass wir bisher noch
niemanden töten konnten ich wollte sagen
müssten aber wir konnten niemanden töten
so der templates einfach komplett ja
alles klar alles klappt alles gut alles
gut wir können kämpfen einfach kämpfen
so aber es geht relativ schnell mit
diesen schwer
einfach kämpfen dass es am ende so mein
lieber mach was du willst du siehst es
vielleicht vielleicht lag ich sage ich
es danach er wollte sie fragen ob ich es
danach sage aber warum soll ich meinen
namen sagen mir ja ich hab das nicht ich
hab das nicht
bogen ich weiß nicht wenn du mir ein
bogen geben will
ok wenn nicht dann nicht dann kämpfen
einfach so seine entscheidung glaubt
immer ein oder nicht airdrop mehr ein
sehr geil ich natürlich mit ok ok ok
asking cruiser rasch und so leute dann
packen das jetzt so ach ich mag nicht so
viel chatten sorry kommen einfach
kämpfen einfach kämpfen
der andere der andere hat er auch im
herausgefunden dass ich es bin
die maschinen dann ausgepackt
man feiert der hat nicht mehr so viele
leben sagte ich habe das gesehen habe
den fall ins tnt reingeschossen okay
jetzt renter weg ich habe keinen hut
mehr der ich hab mir das ein problem
problem jetzt kommt der lack ab ob
jemand schon chance erkennt man startet
erst blockte
ich bin nah dran ich bin daran und du
hast mir viele dem
kommt kommt dort nicht mehr leben ich
muss jetzt voll rein ich habe keine
chance zu retten
ich konnte nicht hinten hat es gesehen
ich konnte nicht einfach nicht hätten
das gibt es nicht ja eh keinen fall
das gibt's nicht ich konnte einfach
schicken kommen daun
bitte geh grauen alter sowie knapp hätte
noch zwei herzen
alter schwede ja wahrscheinlich konnte
er reagan fakt dass das problem ich
hatte keinen mut aber hey leute dass wir
noch mal dazu die challenge war sehr
schwer
wenn ihr wollt dass ich die noch mal in
zwei begann es mache da ist es bestimmt
deutlich leichter dann schreibt man die
kommentare das war es soweit vom
heutigen video
ich hab die challenge nicht meistern
können aber probleme selbst zu hause aus
die baugleich das wäre keine ahnung was
mich wissen bis dann haut rein macht's
gut und ciao